okay so a lot of people on this one we
got robbed you get jay-z got myself the
hell are you Sonne from New Jersey
please just keep oh my name is Brandon
Boyd so and donated money to these guys
and they decided to hang out with me
which has been pretty awesome I don't
know if we get to show you Adventure
Time I know and there's no other way you
know other way to do it right well you
have to come right here in concert to
know so that's please so okay so this is
actually out but the episode we got is
was a hail to the king loyalty loyalty
to the king and this is actually the
first episode that Brandon and Rob have
seen
so obviously seeing how somebody has
donated quite a bit Rob what do you
think Burt obviously very bizarre very
hilarious
only the main question I kept thinking
the whole time is how the hell is this
mint on like the kids like programming
party yeah this is true but I some of
the things that they're like you know
the headless ya know there's some stuff
that I say in the show that bloody cat
that seems a little risque like they use
the word sexy sometimes was a monster it
was a monster true it's okay if it's a
monster and it was also a frog house
like goo it wasn't red but yeah that's
always that some things like to get
around with sensors like if they make
the blood a different color like it's
okay which still makes no sense I mean
by Oh
but apparently yeah so but I think to
like for the most part stuff can be seen
for like like kids can watch it too
yeah so but I think like a lot of
families whenever I go to cons like so
many people are dressed up like these
characters so I mean it's yeah so I
think you can sort of be like half and
half how did you not think this was the
greatest show ever made this is the most
awesome thing I've ever seen either I
said that I could talk about it it's
like a special waste of the first
episode it was so hard to talk about it
and it with this way at least there's a
little bit of a story for the first one
it's like just pure insanity randomness
so no it's I never - I didn't like it or
I didn't get I said I would talk about
it just awesome I guess I loved surreal
non sequitur theaters so this is right
up my alley well and this like I said
this one Angie has more of a story as
opposed to some of the other ones I
actually did leave her at 9:00 so novae
and that's one of the things I really
like is that because with this one like
you can sort of get an idea where the
story is kind of going where it's gonna
amount to it's like with half the other
ones it's like you have no clue and
that's part of the fun but even the ones
where you do kinda what's gonna happen
you like the characters like this one
the Ice King I guess is one of the big
favorites and he looks great without a
fear I love the bad thing really
designed to look like really likable cuz
you can't thing like oh what weird how
they gotta make it look really odd or
weird it's like they make him look like
actually good and we rode back when the
princesses get fast yes
look what and what I kind of like about
this one - is that like it's always this
world that they create is always are
like half love BW and nice and cheerful
but also half really selfish and
everyone always hearts on the Ice King
for being like oh is it be terrible
trying to you know kidnap the princess
is you know there's supposed to be a
happy universe well you see it's like
Brian and pink and stuff like I was
gonna say this universe is fuck you know
it's a very scary universe as well dark
what I always say this is like a bonus
show I say I love it it's like it mixed
between extremely masculine extremely
feminine at the same time like
everything's very private colorful but
like what the talking about in doing and
like the setup for and the character
this is like actually broaden our
definition of feminine okay I mean like
the really aggressive like the fin is
very aggressive and how much he wants to
do very kind helpful things you know but
like he just loves helping people to a
point where it's like you know I'll
punch things for helping you know and
that's part of the fun ya know there's a
lot of stuff like that that's part of
why it's so great so I guess but with
this episode again you get more of the
Ice King being pretty pathetic and sort
of even more selfish like some of this
stuff out saying it's like man that is
like really harsh but think it kind of
levels off because the princess is a
kind of selfish - like I like to just
hear nice King it's like oh well and
they just want to go - and suddenly like
they want to throw themselves to the
ground for him like - please and it's
like just cuz this kind of feels like a
prison like one of them goes I just want
you to know I love the Opera unless you
hate it then I hate it too
yeah I think it's re-established to like
some just are like just very selfish
nothing they're like I loved it won the
opening yes just like save me Finn and
Jake yeah quiet
save me finish like that's all she knows
and she keeps saying yeah it's like just
a very generic the interview part was my
fans like all like five seconds yeah
there's a lot of running away waving
arms in this one no he gets a lot of
laughs
so yeah I think it's just so much
funnier that rather than make like the
Ice King really like ugly or we're
looking so that they make him really
good when he gets like the fitness soon
and he's like all bits like it's really
funny and I just like that direction yet
he still doesn't change he's just as big
a jerk but I guess cuz he looks good now
the women camera I thought was funny oh
that I thought was just good to give you
and how about you Jason I just like how
Robin Barris is you by saying what's
wrong with you the show is amazing send
all of your hate mail to Doug shut up
look at out Reggie's getting letters
Brenda I know God reflecting off the how
about you so I guess since you
apparently have no things you hit every
nail on the head with this one
like with it's all comes down to
everyone so shallow that it doesn't
matter how much of an ass he's writing
around literally on the hot dog princess
they're still like this yeah why are
they going in a circle it's like all
these things that finally comes through
to him he's just like he does even know
what to do if they say let's just walk
around in a circle why isn't this played
at every school in America
you can so educate why is this guy's
would literally be walking around on
girls what schools and you know same
ones you did honey yeah those were hard
what do you think then thing I notice
don't know if this is like a probably
thing with the jerk
series in general which I'll definitely
have to find out now since this was
quite hilarious and great but the
background stuff going on that is just
completely hilarious but it's not
focused at all like for this episode my
favorite was the zombie princess not
even giving a title you can just tell
the whole time she's sitting there like
I like a guard on the bar yeah and
they're like she was there whenever
they're walking around in circle it's
just her like about the whole time I
don't like even addresses it but the
fact it's there is just hilarious
there's something else they doing this
show which I like and I noticed there's
one I guess one of the princess have had
like a bunch of different heads or
whatever and they all pass away but what
they do is have to always have one
that's just like totally different one
is like great and again kinda looks like
a zombie has like sharp teeth it's just
they write like that and you just never
see and you don't know the story with it
there's one where there's like a series
of balloons and they all have happy
faces except for one that has like an
old man's face yeah and they never
explained it so it's little things like
my head princess we're off to see the
nice King well and I think some of you
talked about the background well there's
always that I found after Jason there's
always a snail in every single episode
this specific snail really is just
waving it always there so it's like the
answer these puzzles in cat there I go
yes or the pineapple inside but it's not
as obvious as the cat yeah it's always
like for you boys you know where it is
this is more like Where's Waldo kind of
wears snail and mainly no but like
there's something else in this one that
I think is kind of come on again just
sort of creates this fun inviting
environment is that in the background
there was like there's a sword in a
and then there's like a broken sword
also today and there's one entry and
there's like a skull and it's like
what's the story with that what happened
there it's like venturous anything that
was now that's educational and teaches
spatial learning you got to search for
the snail and find it and that's so you
be running every school every school
sometimes it's a pain in the ass cuz the
snail is only on screen for that long
and it sucks
oh you sly sons of bitches I've only had
to look online once for one snail you
know what I think we need to stop this
conversation right now what do you have
learn nothing soon soon embrace Hitler
nail oh actually within this eating
session you will learn about snail love
mm-hmm
so it's been a great time by saying this
Cartoon Network I'm not gonna say
Citizen Kane worthy well actually you
know what
you should mock Nickelodeon he might
have Nickelodeon and they said no
Niccolo Bailey I'm not gonna say you're
a bunch of fucking imbeciles this are
the things they do with avatar Korra
who's running that Network voice yeah if
you have a good thing Nick
so that's it oh well you'll see yes
hopefully you'll see this man sandwich
in the next one - if not disappointed
you forgot the segue